hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast assessment of the
aerodigestive system in rubies and
presented by Meghan Heaney a laboratory
animal resident and post doctoral fellow
at University in Missouri i'm susie
valdez of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen type that question into the
drop down box that appears on that
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble hearing or seeing the
presentation please click on the help
desk located on the promotional board at
the bottom center of your screen or use
that as a question box this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the accreditation by button
located on the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen and follow
the process to obtain those credits
without further ado join me in welcoming
our presenter today Meghan Haney I will
now turn the presentation over to her
welcoming it thank you very much for
that introduction I'm really excited to
be talking to everyone today about some
approaches that we use in our lab for
longitudinal assessment of the arrow
digestive system in rodents and so to
begin I'm going to just go over a brief
outline of what we'll be talking about
and so the first thing is really to
hammer in what the what the arrow
digestive system actually is and and why
it might pose a challenge to assess this
in animal models and how we
overcome that and so today I'll be
mostly focusing on two different imaging
techniques video fluoroscopy and
endoscopy and these are really the gold
standard diagnostic tests for use in
humans with any sort of aerodigestive
dysfunction and so I want to talk about
how we've kind of I dented these
techniques for use in our rodent species
so first off what the actual
aerodigestive system is is it's really
just a combination of the respiratory
tract along with the upper digestive ACK
and the reason we kind of combine these
two is because they share a lot of the
same structures and they're both really
involved with swallowing vocalization
and breathing and so as you can see on
this image here a lot of the structures
in these two systems are the same and so
it ranges anything from the nasal cavity
to the tongue to the larynx and then to
the esophagus and trachea and so when
there's a dysfunction in one of these
structures are one of these tracks it
often affects the other and so they're
often studied together as a unit and so
that really is your arrow digestive
system and so there's a multitude of
disorders that result in aerodigestive
dysfunction and they can range anywhere
from different congenital disorders to
laryngeal stenosis vocal fold paralysis
motility disorders such as
gastroesophageal reflux along with other
motility disorders pulmonary disorders
as long along with neoplasia and any
sort of neurologic disease especially
neurodegenerative neurodegenerative
disorders including ALS Parkinson's
disease and stroke and these are just to
name a few
there's plenty more disorders that could
result in aerodigestive dysfunction and
so I'm gonna have a lot of videos for
you to watch today
and the first one I want to show you is
a patient a human patient that has vocal
fold paralysis and so in the video
you'll be able to see this is a still
frame of some of the video you'll see
you'll be able to see the vocal folds
which is that v6 v-shaped structure
along with their written oeid cartilages
which are those more prominent
protuberances that you can see and
basically what you'll be looking for is
one side is moving while the other side
is paralyzed and this is vocal fold
unilateral vocal fold paralysis that is
one disorder that can results
aerodigestive to spin so we'll go ahead
and play that video now
you
okay so hopefully you were able to
appreciate the vocal fold paralysis and
so with aerodigestive dysfunction
because there are multiple different
disorders that can cause a dysfunction
in the system you it might be resent
represented by a few different types of
symptoms and included in this is
anything from choking persistent cough
dysphasia or impaired swallowing or
swallow dysfunction frequent vomiting or
regurgitation voice changes high-pitched
noisy breathing recurrent pneumonia
which could be due to aspiration and so
these patients often lose the ability to
protect their airway and so food and
liquid material can get into the lungs
and especially if they have gastro
esophageal reflux you might have
bacterial products coming from the GI
tract that could then be aspirated into
the lungs and so pneumonia can be a
pretty life-threatening complication for
these patients some other symptoms you
might run across is resistant asthma
halitosis are bad breath drooling
Strider hoarseness are just a failure to
thrive or malnutrition and so as you can
see a patient with aerodigestive
dysfunction may have one or multitude of
these different symptoms just depending
on what the cause of the dysfunction
actually is and so the better
understands the aerodigestive tract and
its pathology associated with it and
then to explore potential therapeutics
and treatments for these various
disorders it's important that we have an
animal model on an especially one that
can replicate some of these symptoms
that we're seeing in these people and so
a lot of the ideal models are mice and
rats they're typically what you see in
research however as you can see by this
image there's quite a bit of a size
difference between the layer
drinks of a mouse versus one of a human
and so this size difference and some
anatomical differences definitely
creates a pretty unique challenge in
assessing this system in these small
animals and so this is what we'll focus
on the rest of the talk is really
exploring how we can look at this small
system and these animals and so the
first imaging technique I'd like to talk
to you all about today would be video
fluoroscopy or just basically x-ray
video and there's a few different things
we can assess with video fluoroscopy one
of these is mastication or chewing just
drinking itself and then there's a few
different stages of swallowing in the
mice we can actually evaluate all stages
of swallowing including the oral
pharyngeal and esophageal stage of
swallowing and then rat since they're a
little bigger we can assess the oral and
Ferengi allege and rats and so I'll go
through a video fluoroscopy first with
you and then we'll go into endoscopy so
the video fluoroscopic swallow study or
VF SS is the gold standard diagnostic
test in humans for dysphasia or swallow
swallow dysfunction diagnosis and
basically people are allowed to drink
either a thin liquid thick liquid our
hard food consistency that has an oral
contrast solution in it so that you'll
be able to see the fluid or food bolus
being swallowed with x-ray and you can
do this in a lateral or an anterior
posterior view and these are just still
images of a human patient drinking a
fluid bolus and you can see the dark
contrast in the esophagus on the lateral
and the AP view and so it's better to
better visualize this again I have
another video for you all to watch and
the first clip you will see just a
normal VF SS procedure where the patient
has normal swallow function you'll see
the fluid bolus start up
in the mouth on the upper left portion
of the screen and then it'll swallow in
the food fluid bolus will fall into the
esophagus or be contracted into the
esophagus a part of this clip the next
clip you'll see is a patient with
dysphasia our swallow dysfunction with
associated aspiration and so again the
fluid bolus will start in the oral
cavity and be transported through the
pharynx and it they attempt to swallow
the fluid bolus and most of it goes into
the esophagus but you'll see a small
string of the fluid bolus actually be
aspirated into the trachea towards the
front or anterior portion of the person
so we'll go ahead and play the video
you
who are all able to appreciate the
aspiration of the fluid down the trachea
and obviously it would be heading into
the lungs and so patients with
aspiration any type of aspiration are
definitely more at risk for having
aspiration pneumonia and recurring
pneumonias that often has recurring
treatments involved with that and so the
question is is can we perform this
diagnostic test in our rodent species
that we are using to study these various
disorders in the lab and so our main
quest was to be able to find a way to
allow mice and other rodents to
basically freely drink in oral contrast
solution and be able to perform VF SS in
our rodent species and so this can
actually be done and all it really takes
is a specialized chamber which you can
see on the bottom left and the mouse in
on the top left and basically there's a
little bowl attached to the end cap in
the chamber that you can hook a syringe
to and the syringe is filled with a
palatable oral contrast solution that
when the mice is freely behaving and
freely drinking the fluid you can video
record and get a nice visualization of
the mouse swallowing this fluid bolus
and so what is nice about this is that
the mice we do do some priming with the
mice we get them used to the oral
contrast solution as well as get them
used to the chamber so before testing
we'll put one of the chambers in their
home cage with them with the end cap off
and it's actually really a nice form of
enrichment they just love snuggling up
in there the night before so when you go
to test on the next day they're usually
all snuggled up together in the tube so
they actually really enjoy the tube and
it's so it's not aversive when you go to
actually test the animal so what's
unique about our video fluoroscopic
Swallow studies in our mice is that
we're using a low-energy fluoroscope and
so the advantage of this fluoroscope is
that it actually allows better image
resolution for us to be able to see the
small structures in this small species
so with your normal flora scopes that
you would find in a vet clinic they're
high-energy and so when you go to look
at the mouse you really can't make heads
or tails of what you're seeing so the
low-energy fluoroscope as you can see
here the mouse is placed in the chamber
on a specialized lift where we can use
an electronic control to basically lower
and raise the lift and move the lift
backwards and forwards so we can get the
mouse in the position in front of the
camera of where we want the mouse to be
and so then the mouse will just freely
drink the oral contrast solution and
we'll be able to visualize swallows and
so in the mouse we have two main
positions we look at we have position 1
or P 1 where we're assessing the oral
and perennial stage of swallowing and
you can see highlighted by the arrow you
can see the fluid bolus in the back of
the throat of the mouse and the star is
indicating the tongue of the mouse and
so we can collect quite a few different
metrics from this position including
lick rate John Owen Ferengi old transit
time along with swallow rate and then in
position 2 we move the mouse forward a
little bit on the camera and we can
really assess the esophageal stage of
swallowing where the fluid bolus is
leaving the pharynx and flowing down the
esophagus into the stomach and with this
position we're able to get various
metrics including esophageal transit
time as well as if there's any a
backward flow of the fluid bolus and
various metrics of the esophageal stage
of swallowing and so this allows us to
objectively quantify swallowing in these
in these mice and again I'll be showing
you a video in a few minutes
so that you can actually appreciate the
mice drinking but the mice they drink
really fast so they drink about 10 times
faster than a person would and so you
can you'll be able to see the mouse
they'll just be looking at top speed of
this fluid contrast solution and so what
we have to do is really go frame by
frame and analyze these metrics frame by
frame
to really get a good accurate objective
measure of their swallowing behavior and
so again I'll be showing you the
position 1 and the position 2 but before
I show you the video I have them all
kind of combined so you can see it all
once but we've really hammered down our
drinking metrics RV FSS drinking metrics
and so we wanted to also look at
mastication are chewing chewing motions
in the mice and so this is a mouse
eating a barium infused pellet and so
with this we can actually get the mouse
will kind of gnaw on the pellet to get
some food particles in the mouth and
then start doing more of a grinding
motion and so we're working to come up
with objective metrics for mastication
that could help further distinguish
between health and disease conditions in
these models and help evaluate treatment
when we apply various treatments and so
in humans dysphasic symptoms are most
severe in patients when they're drinking
very thin liquids or eating hard dry
foods and so our testing strategies are
basically trying to emulate this so we
can make this model and process as
translates translational as we can and
then again we obviously we want to know
normals in our mice but then we want to
be able to assess a disordered
swallowing as well and so in our lab we
utilize a mod
of amyotrophic lateral sclerosis or ALS
which is a motor neuron disease and this
is a mouse towards end stage and on the
video you'll be able to see the mouse
can not hold its head up very high it's
going to be looking a little bit slower
you'll see the fluid kind of swirling
around in the mouth before the mouse is
actually able to swallow it and then
when we move to the esophageal stage
you'll see the mouse is pretty chaotic
and it just definitely is it differs
between the normal mice so when I'm
going to play the video here in a second
but you'll be able to appreciate normal
VF SS in position 1 in position 2 some
mastication and then a BFS s of our ALS
model so we'll go ahead and play that
video
you
okay so I hope you were able to
appreciate the fast drinking speed that
these mice can have and then with our
ALS model how you could definitely
appreciate some swallow dysfunction in
this mouse and so again we want to not
just look at these videos but we want to
put some objective numbers to these to
the results that we're getting are the
outcome metrics we're getting from our
VF SS and so this is just an example of
some of the data we can produce with
this testing and so basically what
you're looking at here is the lick rate
and swallow rate between our control
wild-type Mouse compared to two
different strains of an ALS mouse model
and you can see that the liquor a and
the swallow rate are significantly
decreased compared to wild-type
age-matched controls and this is just a
small sampling of some of the data that
you can get what's nice about this
testing is we can actually distinguish
between disorders and so one type of
dysphasia in one model might not be the
same type of dysplasia phenotype in
another model so we also look at just
old age and press the fascia or
difficulty swallowing with old age and
so on this graph were again looking at
swallow and lick right and in on the
Left we have a swallow rate comparing
wild-type control mice compared to two
models of ALS and then an aged just b6
model whereas the follow rate has
decreased in ALS mice it hasn't
necessarily decreased in age model but
when you look at lick rate that has
decreased in our age model along with
the ALS Mouse ALS mouse model and so
because of these different metrics we
can actually start phenotyping our
dispersion models so they might have
different phenotypes of dysphasia
depending on which disorder they have
and so I mentioned we had to do all of
this analysis frame by frame
which is a 30 frames per second so every
second we're looking at 30 frames and so
it's very very time-consuming so we are
actually working with computer science
and engineering on campus to come up
with different tracking software to
better automate our BFS s outcome
measures and so this is an example of
how that tracking might work and so in
image a we have a marker on the upper
jaw in the blue arrow and then we have a
marker on the lower jaw with the red
arrow and basically with these markers
it can track the vertical movement in
motion of these jaw portions and so the
upper arrow or the blue arrow is mostly
just getting head motion that upper jaw
doesn't really move with licking or
swallowing where the bottom jaw is
definitely doing most of the jaw motion
for drinking the fluid and so basically
we can track these movements and then
compensate for overall head movement so
that we can get just the particular draw
movement important for licking and
swallowing um so that's definitely in
the works and will help definitely help
the high throughput of our studies as we
go along and so we've got this technique
pretty perfected in mice and we have
recently started moving to using the
study technique in rats and so with rats
they are obviously bigger but it's a
similar process we've specially designed
chambers for the rats that also have the
bowl that they can drink an oral
contrast solution on the rats and the
mice do differ in what they find
palatable so we've actually been working
with a pet food palatability company to
really narrow down a species specific
formula for our mice and our rats and
with rats because they're bigger we have
to split up the oral phase phase of
swallowing from the
and so you'll be able to appreciate that
here in another video but the oral stage
we're really assessing jaw motion and
lick rate and function of the tongue
we're in the Ferengi estate we can look
at Ferengi old transit time along with a
swallow rate unfortunately because the
rats are so big to fit in our field of
view we can't do image the esophageal
phase as of right now but that's
something we would like to work forward
in the future and then we also have a
specialized food pellets for the rats as
well so we can assess mastication in the
rats and so again it'll be similar to
the mice how they kind of know off a
little portion of the pellet and then
have a more grinding motion afterwards
to really chew the food up before they
swallow it and so basically we're
working on ways to quantify these
different motions with mastication so
we'll go ahead and play another video
showing you the FSS rats
so we've really covered a flora video
fluoroscopy our video for us copy
capabilities in our rodent models so now
we're going to kind of shift gears to
another imaging technique or endoscopy
mm and this is another pretty standard
test in human medicine to look at vocal
folds motion as well as look for learned
really annotation or aspiration and so
with what we've been able to replicate
in the lab we can look at vocal fold
motion dynamics with spontaneous
breathing along with laryngeal a doctor
reflexes which I'll talk about here in a
few slides but that's basically just a
reflex that your vocal folds will close
really fast to basically protect your
airway from any food that might be
heading that way and then we also have
been able to visualize swallowing in our
rodent species and then this has the
potential for tracheal and esophageal
studies as well so to start off with
endoscopy in human medicine it is
referred to as fiber-optic endoscopic
evaluation of swallowing with or without
sensory testing and it's quite a
mouthful and I have a star by the
fiber-optic because sometimes you might
hear it referred to as flexible and
that's basically because they're using a
flexible exa Belynda scope that they
insert through the nasal cavity and it
will go through the nasal cavity and
into the pharynx and basically look down
right on top of the vocal folds and so
with this you can assess vocal fold
motion and movement along with
swallowing and so again I'm going to
show you another video of how this works
and so the first clip you'll see there's
a steel frame on the left of the video
is basically you'll be able to see the
vocal folds which are deeper down in the
structure and that open space would be
the opening of the trachea and
your epiglottis is on the bottom of the
screen and this first video is just
going to show a normal dry swallow
they're not swallowing any fluid or
anything it's just a swallow and it's in
slow motion so you can really appreciate
the epiglottis folding back and coming
over to protect the Airways on the other
hand the patient in the second clip has
aspiration and so they will be drinking
a contrast are a thin liquid fluid with
a dye in it so you can better visualize
the fluid and the epiglottis is unable
to come in front of the trachea and so
they actually aspirate it so we'll go
ahead and play in that video so you can
appreciate that better
you
so to perform a endoscopy and human
patients again you're using a flexible
endoscope that goes through the nasal
cavity and you can see this is the an
image of one of those on the top here
obviously there's two big challenges
with using this technology in rodents is
one it's going to be really hard to find
something small enough to go into the
nasal cavity along with their Anatomy it
just you probably want to get a good
visualization of the vocal folds and um
they're obviously not going to really
sit still for this procedure either so
with endoscopy we do have to use a light
anesthetic to be able to basically just
immobilize the animal for this procedure
and so and again their small size poses
quite a bit of a challenge and so we've
actually started using a cyl endoscope
which is actually designed to visualize
the salivary ducts and is used to scope
the salivary ducts in humans and so
we've adapted the Selinda scope for use
for transoral and asked in our rodents
and so instead of going through the
nasal cavity we're going to go through
the oral cavity adjust the epiglottis
out of the way so we can visualize the
vocal folds and what's nice about our
endoscope is that it has a working
channel so we can pass air or fluid or
even a mechanical type probe of some
sort through the working channel that
would come out the other end
into the animal and so we've actually
worked with our physics shop on campus
to come up with a few different
laryngoscope tips that can be inserted
on to over the end of the scope of
depending on which function or purpose
we're using an endoscopy for we might
use a different tip so here's kind of
what that looks like we have a great
student in our lab that can draw amazing
pictures and so basically the mouse is
placed in
a recumbent C and we after it's been
lightly anesthetized and we gently
retract the tongue to allow insertion of
the endoscope and then the second image
on the right is just a sagittal view of
the endoscope inserted into the oral
cavity the epiglottis is coupled with
the soft palate in mice and so they have
to be uncoupled which is basically just
put light pressure down on the
epiglottis or on the soft palate and the
epiglottis will cup and then you'll be
able to visualize the vocal folds and
our endoscope is controlled on a micro
manipulator and so you can adjust have
fine-tune adjustments of the control of
the endoscope which makes it a lot
easier to handle with the with the mice
so this is the view that you would see
on the end of the endoscope when you're
looking at the vocal folds so the white
arrows are actually pointing to the
vocal folds they're pretty small in mice
and then right underneath them the more
prominent structures you see are
actually the written oyk cartilages and
remember the mouse is in dorsal
recumbent C so dorsal is down towards
the bottom of the screen and the white
star is indicating the trachea and for
mice and rats they actually breathe
spontaneously while under anesthesia so
so their vocal folds are moving
spontaneously with their breathing you
don't need to evoke a response of any
sort so you can just monitor their vocal
fold movement without having to do any
sort of stimulation of any for any kind
so again I'm going to show you another
video of the vocal folds in action so in
a normal Mouse you'll see nice normal
bilateral symmetric vocal fold motion
where we are actually looking at vocal
fold paralysis as another model in our
lab and so the next video you'll see
will be the right vocal fold will
actually be paralyzed so it will be
immobile and the left side will still
remain moving and so I hope you'll be
able to appreciate the differences in
these focal full motion dynamic
so we'll go ahead and play that video
you
so it's pretty easy to tell the
difference between fully fully motion
full motion of the vocal folds versus
paralysis but we're trying to
investigate various treatments and so
there's going to be some partial
recovery of the vocal fold movement in
these mice and most current methods are
pretty subjective in assessing the
amount of recovery with the vocal folds
or use angles or areas that can be a
little bit hard to interpret so we're
again we're working with computer
science to develop some automated
tracking of vocal fold movement and
basically what this entails is just
marking vocal folds and then being able
to track their movement in a lateral
medial and lateral directions and
basically get a total range of motion as
well as the frequency of motion as well
and so I'm going to play you these
videos and you'll be able to see normal
motion with our video trackers
post-injury so there have had a injury
to the nerve that controls the vocal
fold and so you'll have unilateral vocal
fold paralysis and then in the last clip
you'll see some partial recovery that it
might be hard to interpret and quantify
how much that recovery actually is
without some sort of objective measure
so we'll go ahead and play those
you
you
vocal fold was moving but maybe not up
to par with the left side and so with
our objective measures we can actually
quantify and graph out the vocal fold
motion and so if you look at the tracing
underneath these still images of the
vocal folds you can see the red is the
right vocal fold and the blue is the
left vocal fold and so with normal
bilateral movement you'll see
oscillations of the left and right vocal
fold and so they're moving towards a
similar amplitude on the graph where in
our post-injury mouth that red line is
pretty flat indicating that right vocal
fold is not moving where you have normal
oscillations of the left vocal fold and
then in our partial recovery Mouse you
can also see you have normal range of
motion in the left side indicated by the
blue and then the red tracing you can
tell that the again the right vocal fold
is moving but it's not to the same
amplitude as the left side and so from
that information we can collect a couple
of different objective measures
including the mean motion range ratio
where basically we're taking the range
of motion of the right side and
comparing it to the left side and in a
certain study that we did post crush you
can definitely see some impaired right
vocal fold motion compared to the left
side immediately post crush and three
days after crush that starts to recover
by two weeks and then we can also look
at cycle ratio which is basically just a
frequency based measure and how
basically how many times the right vocal
fold is moving compared to the left
vocal fold so the frequency again
basically significantly decreases post
crush and then starts to recover by two
weeks and so these are just some
examples of some of the objective
measures we can get with our automated
track so sometimes we might want to do a
little bit more than just look at
spontaneous breathing we might want to
test the vocal fold out a little bit
more if you will and so there's a reflex
called the laryngeal adductor reflex
where basically it's a brief closure of
the vocal folds in response to some sort
of stimulus acting on the mucosa of the
vocal folds and it's a defensive airway
reflex and so those vocal folds pick up
that something might be entering the
airway they closed really fast
to try and prevent that from coming into
into the airway and so we actually have
a it's called the ll I Lieber Lab
infinity where we can deliver puffs of
air through the endoscope that act as a
stimulus of something hitting that
mucosa and it will induce the laryngeal
eye-doctor reflex in our mice and so on
the bottom of this slide you can see the
different phases of the learner and
you'll adductor reflex basically there's
an adduction phase where the vocal folds
are coming together you have a complete
glottic closure where the vocal folds
are completely touching each other are
closed and then an abduction phase where
the vocal folds are coming back apart
and you'll see some more videos of this
in a second we the first video will be
one of a human lar learned your abductor
reflex and we're actually working on
using our trackers in humans as well as
our rodent models and so this particular
video will have the tracking lines on
the vocal folds and then following the
human video I'll show you a mouse learn
Joe a doctor reflex it's very fast so
I've slowed it down to 10% speed so
you'll be able to really appreciate
those vocal folds coming together and
the complete glottic closure
what you actually can see on this slide
on the right you can see the vocal folds
coming together and then following the
slowed down video I will show you
another video of multiple lar s in a row
where we're basically trying to target
the different sides and only elicit a
response from either the left or the
right side
we'll go ahead and play those
you
I've noticed especially on that last
video how quick those lar s in the mouse
are and so again this is another imaging
modality where we have to really analyze
frame by frame to come up with our
objective measures and so again we're
working on automating and doing a
tracking algorithms to really put this
process through make it high-throughput
where we don't have to sit down and
manually do a analyze each video and so
the nice thing about our lar again it
can help distinguish between different
disorders so again here's just some of
the metrics you can get you can get the
duration of time of the whole lar along
with the adduction phase the glottic
phase got a cloture phrase and the
abduction phase and again it shows
differentiation between our control mice
are aging b6 mice and then our ALS model
and so in our our aging - they have a
significantly decreased glottic closure
compared to the other two groups and
then our ALS model actually has a
decreased abduction phase and so again
it helps distinguish between different
disorders of the aerodigestive tract and
so besides just a vocal fold movement we
also want to be able to visualize and
measure swallowing in these animal
animal models and so we can use
endoscopy for this process as well so
basically we can insert our endoscope
and rather than going far enough in that
you get to the vocal folds you actually
keep the epiglottis coupled with the
soft palate and so you're just in the
middle of the oral cavity basically and
there's two main mechanisms for inducing
swallowing in a mouse that's
anesthetized and one of them is with
electrical stimulation and so you can
see in the image on the right we have
done a ventral neck incision to expose
the trachea and the layer
drinks and we're actually targeting the
superior learn Jill nerve which is the
sensory nerve in the swallow reflex and
so you can actually provide an
electrical stimulus to this nerve and it
will induce a swallow obviously this is
pretty invasive it takes a surgical
procedure to do this so another method
is to actually use a chemically induced
stimulus and so we can actually do that
working channel of the endoscope insert
a small amount of fluid in this case
citric acid it's two point seven percent
citric acid so it's similar to lemon
juice or some sort of orange juice or
something like that so it's nothing that
would be toxic or harmful in any way but
basically how this acts on the receptors
in that mucosa of the oral cavity and
elicits a swallow response as well and
so there's two ways to really visualize
this with the surgery option you can see
movement of the larynx and then you can
also see appreciate the movement of the
larynx in the mouth as well and so I'll
just play a short video so you can
appreciate that as well
you
and so this image is actually showing
the endoscopic view of the swallow so
just to orient you a little bit on top
you'll have the tongue base because
remember the mouse is in dorsal
recumbent see the structure in the
middle is the epiglottis and then the
soft palate is on the bottom and so I'll
show you a video of the endoscope being
inserted and then two different
instances of swallowing so you'll be
able to see that you'll be able to see
the tongue base basically coming
together with the soft palate
signifying a swallow so we'll go ahead
and play that video
you
you
I'm fluid in the oral cavity that was
swallows induced with this 2.7% citric
acid so we're still working on objective
measures to really quantify the
swallowing with this technique but can
definitely be a useful modality lastly I
just want to briefly touch on maybe some
trachea lore esophageal studies that you
might want to do the endoscope can be
inserted into the trachea as well as the
esophagus and so the downside with using
mice and rats is because of their
Anatomy they're more like human infants
where they have that epiglottis and soft
palate coupled together kind of hiding
the larynx away so they don't really
aspirate so if you want to study
aspiration in a mouth you have to
actually go and induce it and so with
endoscope it actually makes this really
easy because you can just again go open
up the airways and insert through the
working channel some small tubing and
you can actually insert whatever
material you're using to induce
aspiration so in this case just proof of
concept on the bottom end it image we
can see the tubing entering the trachea
an image beyond the bottom bottom left
and then on a and B on the bottom right
you can see some blue fluid dye that
we've actually inserted into the trachea
and you can visualize all the way down
to the karana or the bifurcation of the
trachea so this would be really helpful
when you want to use this as a model you
can actually ensure that the fluid is
where you want it to go potentially even
doing a left versus a right type of
induction as well so in conclusion the
challenges of rodent models and
especially their small size can
definitely be overcome allowing the
assessment of aerodigestive function and
dysfunction in these mammals along with
treatment effects in these mammals as
well so the gold standard image
techniques that are used in humans can
definitely be applied to rodents though
there are some limitations such as
having to anesthetize the mice lightly
for the endoscopy procedures but again
it can definitely be used to start to
assess different treatment effects in
various disease models of arrow to arrow
digestive dysfunction so some of our
future directions actually most of these
we're currently working on right now but
we are definitely working on automating
our outcome measures so we can have
higher throughput of our studies along
with assessing various treatments we
have quite a few different studies going
on now assessing treatments in our ALS
model as well as our unilateral vocal
fold paralysis model that we have and
then we also are attempting to look at
different EMG and brainstem recordings
during swallowing or during the Larr
reflex as well so with that I would like
to thank everybody in our lab who's had
any portion our part in any of these
projects we have quite a few different
things going on so they kind of make
everything run smoothly definitely those
in the College of Engineering that are
helping us with our automated tracking
and really helping develop that we'd
really be lost without them and then of
course our various funding sources for
these projects so I would love to take
any questions that anyone might have
Thank You Megan and thank you for your
informative presentation and your
important research we will now start
that live Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now audience members just
click on that ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type that question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button so let's get
started and take a look at our current
questions coming in our first question
is will your methods and software be
available for for purchase I'm actually
that would be able to ultimate goal all
right right now we kind of realized that
since we don't have our automated
tracking up and running we realize
nobody is going to want to sit down on a
computer and click frame by frame to
actually come up with these outcome
measures and so I think right now we're
really striving to get our automated
tracking up and running so we can really
help do some high-throughput studies so
we're hoping we can get some of those
simpler metrics fully automated by the
end of the year but for now we're really
open to collaborative studies and it's
someone wants a disease model phenotypes
we're more than willing to help
facilitate that Thank You Megan and
here's our next question what is the
process to have our model of
aerodigestive dysfunction phenotype - by
you so I guess that kind of goes along
with the last question we're super open
to collaboration I know there's a lot of
models out there that could potentially
have some aerodigestive dysfunction
especially maybe dysphasia and so we're
open to some collaborative studies and
basically all you really have to do is
contact our lab at the University of
Missouri and we can basically I'll have
to do a health check of all the mice
that you would are your model that you
want to send to us and then they have to
sit through quarantine for a little bit
kind of standard University policy with
moving animals around between places and
then after the quarantine we can
definitely do all the video fluoroscopic
follow Studies on the mice or rats and
then we can even do an endoscopy studies
as well so turnaround time is usually
about a month after they get through the
quarantine it really just depends on
what your you're looking for so again
we're open to some collaborations that's
wonderful thank you for that and I want
to remind our audience that any
questions that we don't have time for
today will be answered via
we have time for one more question
here's our last question are there any
adverse effects from these procedures at
the first part of the question and the
second part is how often can be FSS and
endoscopy be performed on a single
rodent
okay so we've kind of designed these
tests to be as minimally invasive as
possible I'm an estate for the animal
obviously with video fluoroscopic
swallow studies it is an x-ray so you do
do risks on radiation exposure to the
animals we have everything pretty
blocked off so there's not much human
risk but there's a little bit of risk
for the animal and so typically we try
not to do the FSS studies more than once
or twice a month for the animal it
really depends again on the the
timeframe you're looking at if it's a
long-term study then definitely no more
than probably once a month if it's a
shorter timeframe you might be able to
squeak a little bit more in that time
and then it also kinda depends on the
developing development stage of the
animal if they're earlier in development
they're probably more risk at that
radiation causing a problem later on in
life with our endoscopy procedures there
you can actually perform these at least
once a week we found we've been doing
them weekly in a couple of our models it
does take anesthesia but they seem to
handle that okay weakly so excuse me
there's not too much trouble with that
you do risk sometimes we have found that
you might have food in the mouth so
typically when you do any type of
anesthetic procedure on a rodent you
don't need to food restrict them because
they don't aspirate but we found that we
like to at least food restrict about
four hours before the procedure just so
there's no residual food in the mouth
because especially if we're going into
the airways we don't
to push that food that might be sitting
in the oral cavity down into the into
the trachea with our endoscope so we try
and avoid aspiration that way we've had
one or two mice the endoscope might kind
of scrape the mucosa and cause a little
bit of bleeding in that case we usually
stop the procedure make sure there's
kind of stopped the bleeding as best as
we can wake the mouse up but they're
usually fine for a procedure again the
next week so it's not severe by any
means Meghan thank you again for our
presentation I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you'll receive the
email from labyrinth letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay be sure that announcement with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon but